welcome to this video playing Chucky
crew to cook something like that make
your kinetic wow there are so many I am
I don't know this guy at all okay I'm
probably oops Kings Indian arun felt the
groom felt or the goon head I mean I can
actually pronounce it correctly we have
this this this loud sound in German goon
fed the Greenfield okay so um he just
played h6 online on my age fourth plus
interestingly enough which means
probably he won't castle quickly age
successor hang
well yeah well I haven't we need to know
the opening hmm how is this plate yeah
should i click here maybe miss placing
the night I wish that shouldn't be too
bad and now probably a rock move well I
I don't really know the the lines here I
mean there probably is this position is
probably a theoretically explored one
but with them the pods not being played
slightly five holes yeah after 95 he
probably must take it with the bishop
okay I've got a double pawn but my my
bishops are really nice the bishop
bonnie is three especially nice always
putting this pressure also on the h6
pawn okay so here maybe I need to play a
four right here I need to but it's still
a very nice space advantage and well
okay there's a tech on the edge porn
yeah hmm yeah that's interesting if I go
h5 what is he doing g5 maybe but it's
still a favorable change of porn
structure I'll play g3 and um he will
have to to god this all the time really
he cannot seriously not play g5 here I
don't think so unless there's some
technical thing which I am not seeing
wow I thought this is completely
unplayable
yeah this is not playable okay so let's
see how how do you how do you play this
now I mean the most obvious way is to
taking here and play Bishop deform but
probably it's better to just put it on
the long diagonal and not sacrifice
anything I'm just wondering how it
should be to see three that's a one way
to go the only thing is if he has Luke
cata bishops III might have night moves
to before because of the spent situation
on the C file but still I mean this is
just the king we saw his really black
resigned yeah it looked it look it
doesn't didn't look like playable really
Bishop c3 York c5 and they're both great
i mean i know this is the easiest yeah
this is the easiest and here i just need
to get something on the edge from like
here this yeah they're just this was
very strange I mean after after h5 you
absolutely must play g5 it's the only
playable move right the computer is even
giving this is winning but you must do
that and there is no other move this
just this just gives it to gives it up
basically I don't really think that age
six is a good reply it it looks this
position looks comfortable for me
alrighty this is just one way to go here
I was expecting h5 actually are at least
here age 52 sort of blockade on the on
the King side and then it's just a
normal game I'm playing let's say King
here Bishop here maybe looks over and he
asked this two against one which is lex
trump card and i have the bishops and
this strong upon mass in the center yeah
I like white but this is still a still a
tough tough fight this this is not
really on I mean he must do that it's
not nice but I think you must do that
and then try to try to defend this
position it's not much fun but I guess
it's the way to go get him this is just
just not not on computer what what does
the computer want to do look g8 with
plus form yeah check like this and then
I would have played here the idea is
king f2 and taking so let's say just for
argument's sake you play something like
that check and that check lets them
checkmate that's the mating pattern
young age for continues to be a
dangerous dangerous weapon it seems
alright thanks for watching